I will now do a proof for which we
credit the 12th century Indian
mathematician bas Cara so what we're
going to do is we're going to start with
a square so let me see if I can draw a
square I'm going to draw it tilted as a
bit of an angle just because I think
it'll make it a little bit easier on me
so let me my best attempt at drawing
something that reasonably looks like a
square you have to bear with me if it's
not exactly a tilted square so that
looks that looks pretty good and I'm
assuming it's a square so this is a
right angle this is a right angle
that's a right angle that's a right
angle I'm assuming the lengths of all of
these sides are the same so let's just
assume that they're all of length C I'll
write that in yellow so all of the sides
of the square are of length C and now
I'm going to construct four triangles
inside of this square and the way I'm
going to do it is I'm going to be
dropping so here I'm going to go
straight down I'm going to drop a line
straight down and draw a triangle that
looks like this so I'm going to go
straight down here here I'm going to go
straight across and so since this is
straight down and this is straight
across we know that this is a right
angle then from this vertex on our
square I'm going to go straight up and
since this is straight up and this is
straight across we know that this is a
right angle and then from this vertex
right over here I'm going to go straight
horizontally I'm assuming that's what
I'm doing and so we know that this is
going to be a right angle and then we
know this is going to be a right angle
so we see that we've constructed from
our square we've constructed for right
triangles and in between we have
something that at minimum looks like a
rectangle or possibly a square we
haven't quite proven to ourselves yet
that this is square now the next thing I
want to think about is whether these
triangles are congruent so they
definitely all have the same length of
their hypotenuse all of the hypotenuse
of lauryl hypotenuse is hypotony
hypotenuse --is they have all length C
the side opposite the right angle is all
ways length C so if we can show that
they all the corresponding angles are
the same that we know it's congruent if
you
have something where all the angles are
the same and you have the side that is
also the corresponding side that's also
congruent then the whole triangles are
congruent and we can show that if we
assume that this angle is Theta then
this angle right over here has to be 90
minus theta because together they are
complementary we know that because they
they combine to form this angle of the
square this right angle if this is 90
minus theta we know this angle and this
angle have to add up to 90 because we
only have 90 left when we subtract the
right angle from 180 so we know this has
to be theta and if that's theta then
that's 90 minus theta I think you see
where it's going if that's 90 minus
theta this has to be theta and if that's
theta then this is 90 minus theta if
this is 90 minus theta then this is
Theta and then this would have to be 90
minus theta so we see in all four of
these triangles the three angles are
theta 90 90 minus theta and 90 degrees
so they all have the same exact angle so
at minimum they are similar and their
hypotenuse is are the same so we know
that all four of these triangles are
completely congruent triangles so with
that assumption let's just assume that
the longer side the longer side of these
triangles that these are of length B so
the longer side of these triangles I'm
just going to assume so this this length
right over here that is I'll call that
lowercase B and let's assume that the
shorter side the shorter side so this
distance right over here this distance
right over here this distance right over
here that these are all this distance
right over here that these are of length
a so if I were to say this height right
over here this height is of length that
is of length a now we will do something
interesting well first let's think about
the area of the entire square what's the
entire area of the entire square in
terms of C well that's pretty
straightforward it's a C it's a C by C
it's a C by C square so the area the air
here the area is equal to C squared now
what I'm going to do is rearrange two of
these triangles and then come up with
the area of that other figure in terms
of A's and B's and hopefully it gets us
to the Pythagorean theorem and to do
that just - so we don't lose our
starting point because our starting
point is interesting let me just copy
and paste this entire thing so I don't
want to clip off so let me just copy and
paste this copy and paste so I'm going
to is our original diagram and what I
will now do and actually let me clear
that out clear I'm now going to shift
this is the fun part I'm going to shift
this triangle here in the top left I'm
going to shift it below this triangle on
the bottom right and I'm going to
attempt to do that by copying and
pasting so let's see how much well the
way I drew it it's not that II well that
might do the trick I want to retain a
little bit of the so let me copy or let
me actually cut it and then let me paste
it so that triangle I'm going to stick
right over there stick that right over
there and let me draw in the lines that
I just erased so just to be clear we had
a line over there and we also had we
also had this right over here and this
was straight up and down and these were
straight side to side now so I moved
this part over down here so I move that
over down there and now I'm going to
move now I'm going to move this top
right triangle down to the bottom left
so I'm just rearranging the exact same
area so let me actually let me just
capture the whole thing as best as I can
so let me cut and then let me paste and
I'm going to move it right over here and
I well I went through that process I
kind of lost its floor so let me redraw
the floor so I just moved it right over
here so this thing this triangle my
color in is now right over there
and this triangle this triangle is now
right over here that Center that's
Center square and it is a square is now
right over here so hopefully you can
appreciate how we rearranged it now my
question for you is how can we express
the area of this new figure which has
the exact same area is the old figure I
just shifted parts of it around how can
we express this in terms of A's and B's
well the key insight here is to
recognize the length of this bottom side
what's the length of this bottom side
right over here the length of this
bottom side
well this length right over here is B
this length right over here is a so the
length of this entire bottom is a a plus
B well that by itself is kind of
interesting but what we can realize is
that this length right over here this
length right over here which is the
exact same thing as this length over
here was also a so we can construct an a
by a square so we can construct an a by
a square so this square right over here
is a by a and so it has area a squared
let me do that in a color that you can
actually see so this has area of a
squared and then what's the area of
what's left over well if this if this is
length a then this is length a as well
if this entire bottom is a plus B then
we know that that what's leftover after
subtracting the a out has to be B this
whole thing is a plus B this is a then
this right over here is B and so the
rest of this of this newly oriented
figure this new figure everything that
I'm shading in over here this is just a
B by B Square so the area here is B
squared so the entire area of this
figure is a squared plus B squared which
lucky for us is equal to the area of
this expressed in terms of C because of
the exact
same figure just rearranged so it's
going to be equal to C squared and all
worked out and bhaskar I gave us a very
cool proof of the Pythagorean theorem